imagine walking five kilometers to
school every day under the scorching sun
and no trees not shared inside writing
final exams outside in the dry
slaughtering head and still being
expected to pass with flying colors
and then after school or sometimes
before or sometimes
trekking for hours to the nearest water
source standing in long queues just to
get a few drops from a drying world
this is the daily life of myself
and over thousands of school children in
my city alone and the life of millions
of children all across africa and around
the globe climate change is making our
lives harder
sometimes unbearably so
the injustice however is that climate
change is mostly caused by adults in
developed nations and get it mostly as
children in developing countries
especially when you think about our
dwindling future
we are the ones with the most aesthetic
which is why we need to have a seat at
the table for fighting for climate
justice solutions
my name is ankus latinati i'm a minister
fifth climate advocate and a proud
zimbabwean
i live in a town called victoria falls
which is home to one of the seven
wonders of the world here we call it
morsi ortinia and this is tonga for the
smoke that thunders
a crop bench no timber township a poor
part of our region where many are
struggling
but as a child i noticed on top of
existing economic challenges we started
having new challenges caused by
environmental impact
for example
i started noticing the unpredictability
and uncertainty of weather patterns
sometimes we could have excessive rains
and floods that could wash away our top
soil which we depend on for agriculture
the water will drown our animals destroy
our farmers heart and crops right before
the harvest
and then sometimes the weather patterns
were the opposite
would experience spirits of extreme
droughts no rainfall the land dry and
cracking
our crops were ruined and our animals
died then too
in 2017 we were warned by the local
government not to go to school because
cyclone denial was to hit my region
i read my books in fear that day
from that one tropical storm alone
20 000 homes were destroyed and 130 000
people were displaced in zimbabwe and
mozambique i asked myself
what crime has my generation committed
to deserve this
then just two years later cyclonic die
hit devastating the eastern part of my
country it claimed over 1 000 lives
affecting another 3 million in the
region
schools and homes was destroyed
over 9 000 students had their schooling
disrupted what's wrong have we done to
deserve this
it's hard to beat out no matter what but
especially hard to have a childhood turn
apart by climate disaster after climate
disaster and wonder what the future
holds the present is already such a
struggle why continue fighting is
official bring what destruction
this is a crisis my generation faces and
this is why i became an activist to
fight to even have a future
i decided to ask the questions most
people at my age were not asking why is
this happening
who is to blame and what is to blame is
there anything we can do to stop it to
stop the interruptions to our schooling
to our live laws to stop the fear we
have for the future
since i was 10 i started to recognize
all these changes i became passionate
about climate change and the environment
i joined environmental club since grade
5 and i'm currently the president of the
environmental club at my school in yard
high school
when i was 12 i led the initiation of a
functional biogas plant i learned that
if we combusted food scraps in a special
container that would break down and
provide natural gas that could be tapped
on into a stove to cook on the project
is the first of its kind in victoria
falls hence other people have also
implemented the initiative in their home
states
students can learn about something which
they can see in their premises
it does not only reuse our food and
kitchen waste in a sustainable way but
it means we don't need to rely on
burning fossil fuels
or hold for energy
and in a place like zimbabwe where we
have terrible fuel and power crisis
this helped us survive
from the dusty grounds of my native land
to the blinding lights of madrid and
milan
my activism has led me to measure
climate change events
representing the voices of young people
demanding change
but every time i had the climate
activists speak on a podium they would
point out how we young people not
included in decision making process
something i noted myself back home in
zimbabwe where there are more
opportunities for young people to join
events and speak to important decision
makers now it is the right time to truly
and meaningfully listen to our ideas and
include us in these decisions
i tell you
my consent generation has more to offer
than ever before
this is because we live climate change
in a way our parents generation did not
think of someone in a remote and
marginalized blessed will can't afford
an umbrella but tells to walk to school
in the rain
and is expected to pass and excel
climate change is a child right crisis
it is also children in remote areas in
developing countries who have
contributed less to the bring of this
catastrophe
teach us more about climate change as we
leave it included in our subject in our
school curriculums at all levels
if we as a generation are more informed
we will have more to offer this crucial
period in humanity to solve the climate
crisis it will be upon us when i was 15
victoria falls suffered its greatest
drought in a century
the mighty waters became almost
overnight biliarco beyond just the usual
seasonal changes
at the same time this was happening more
water strategies were befalling all of
africa and 45 million of my fellow
africans were suffering food insecurity
because of crop failures
these kinds of tragedies should never
happen not once during childhood not
ever
they cannot do what looms our horizon we
can fight we can hear our planet with
accountable responsible solutions but
when if we include young people who have
the most attack
because thankfully the waterfall still
rains down but we young people are the
most overturning we are the smoke that
thunders